[Aplausos]
[Música]
fijaos un momento en la camiseta que
lleváis puesta o en vuestros pantalones
vaqueros o incluso en los billetes que
tenéis en el bolsillo todo esto está
hecho de algodón si los billetes también
pues bien tengo una mala noticia que
daros uno de cada cinco podéis estar
llevando ahora un producto hecho por
mano de obra extra
[Música]
es matemática pura mira una cuarta parte
de todo el algodón del mundo se produce
en china pero dentro de china el 88% de
los cultivos de algodón están en la
región de xinjiang y si sois seguidores
ha sido de visual política ya sabéis qué
está pasando ahora en xinjiang
discriminación de la etnia uigur campos
de reeducación y trabajo forzoso vale
volvamos a las matemáticas si una cuarta
parte del algodón mundial se produce en
china en ese algodón el 88% de xinjiang
sólo tenemos que hacer una regla de tres
para averiguar qué porcentaje de algodón
se produce en esta región en la que la
minoría uigur está prácticamente
esclavizada por el gobierno chino
no hace falta que saques la calculadora
ya os lo digo yo el 22% sí como lo es el
22% una quinta parte de todo el algodón
mundial que tanto nos gusta a todos es
fruto de trabajo forzoso y se utiliza
por grandes marcas como h&m adidas nike
o inditex pero por si a alguien le
parece que no es para tanto preparados
porque esto no es lo peor china no es el
único país que se pasa por el de
sus caprichos los derechos humanos en la
producción de algodón y parece que no
pero hay algo peor que el trabajo
forzoso atentos
el mito de los dedos ágiles es
particularmente relevante para la
producción de semillas de algodón donde
los empleadores afirman que las tareas
de polinización cruzada emasculación y
polinización manual la realizan mejor
las niñas que no han alcanzado la
pubertad como es el caso de la india
habéis oído bien en pleno siglo 21
todavía hay productores que defienden el
trabajo infantil y que quede claro no
solamente hablamos de adolescentes sino
de niñas que empiezan a trabajar a
partir de los 5 años
también es muy frecuente que sean
empleados para recoger el algodón porque
frente a los recolectores adultos tienen
dos ventajas uno que como los niños son
más bajitos no tienen que agacharse para
recoger el algodón y dos que cobran
mucho menos que cualquier adulto vamos
que si eres un empresario o un gobierno
sin escrúpulos ni control de ningún tipo
lo mejor que puedes hacer en tu campo de
algodón es esclavizar a un colegio
entero y no lo estoy diciendo en broma
porque hay países que hacen exactamente
esto cuando llega el otoño sacan a todos
los estudiantes de las clases para que
recojan algo no no
y me diréis entonces en este vídeo vamos
a hablar de cosas terribles como la
esclavitud moderna y el trabajo infantil
pues lo cierto es que no porque en medio
de este panorama tan desolador tenemos
una muy pero que muy buena noticia
sigue disminuyendo el trabajo forzoso e
infantil en los campos de algodón de
uzbekistán y diréis pero y esto porque
si recordáis hace varios años en visual
políticos hablamos de un cristal y os
contábamos que es una dictadura salvaje
abyecta y que no tenía el más mínimo
escrúpulo para esclavizar a su población
para que recogieran algodón y por si
alguno se lo preguntaba el mismo
dictador que gobernaba entonces es el
que gobierna ahora hablamos del señor
shavkat mirziyóyev
este respecto no ha cambiado
absolutamente nada los uzbekos siguen
sufriendo un régimen considera que los
derechos humanos son opcionales y os
preguntaréis entonces cómo es posible
que de repente a este dictador le haya
dado un ataque de bondad y vaya a acabar
con el trabajo forzoso infantil que han
venido a ver los fantasmas de dickens y
se ha dado cuenta de que tiene que
cambiar las cosas pues realmente
entonces porque uzbekistán ha decidido
acabar con la mano de obra forzosa
infantil como lo está haciendo y hasta
qué punto puede servir como un modelo
para el resto de países productores de
algodón incluido china hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
está por todas partes puede que
sorprenda pero el algodón es uno de los
diez cultivos más plantados del mundo
tan sólo por detrás del trigo maíz arroz
soja y algunos cereales el 26 por ciento
de toda la tierra cultivada del planeta
son plantaciones de algodón lo que es
más o menos lo mismo que el tamaño de
alemania o de color
ya sabéis que a diferencia del trigo del
maíz el algodón no se come pero aún así
ocupa el doble de la tierra que por
ejemplo las plantaciones de patatas es
más hasta 300 millones de personas es
decir el 3 por ciento de la población
mundial trabajan en alguna de las fases
de la cadena de producción del algodón y
os preguntaréis pero y por qué se planta
tanto algodón si en principio sólo se
utiliza para la ropa y no todas porque
también hay ropa que es de lino o de
cáñamo o de mil tejidos más pues sí pero
resulta que el algodón se utiliza para
todo en esta vida y no sólo hablamos de
ropa
mirad veis este billete de 50 euros pues
en realidad esto es algodón puro y duro'
pensando bien si los billetes fueran de
papel sería imposible que durarán tanto
soportarán la humedad e incluso algún
que otro centrifugado en la lavadora en
cambio al estar hechos con fibra de
algodón son mucho más robustos flexibles
y resistentes pero eso no es todo el
algodón también se utiliza en un sinfín
de objetos que usamos en nuestro día a
día los textiles del hogar los filtros
del café los cordones de los zapatos o
incluso en un montón de componentes para
las pantallas planas de televisión
de las semillas de algodón se extrae el
aceite que se usa en la producción de
jabones en la margarina y en algunos
plásticos es más el algodón se utiliza
está en los trajes espaciales y de hecho
el 2019 china intentó plantar algodón en
la cara oculta de la luna visto el
percal creo que es fácil entender por
qué hay tantos países que se dedican a
cultivar algodón son 90 prácticamente la
mitad del mundo pero los principales
productores son india china y los eeuu
el 'tío sam' es el que más algodón
exporta al resto del mundo por su parte
la unión europea se queda mucho más
atrás sólo se cultiva algodón en españa'
y en grecia y no alcanza ni de cerca a
la producción de otros continentes pero
hoy nos vamos a centrar en una región
diferente en la que el algodón es tan
importante que en proporción son uno de
los mayores productores de este oro
blanco por kilómetro cuadrado y por
habitante vamos que son países tan
dependientes del cultivo del algodón que
incluso lo han dibujado en sus escudos
nacionales y también cuentan con unas
condiciones climáticas bastante
para volcarse a producir el oro blanco
hablamos de asia central o como todos lo
conocemos la tierra de los instantes ya
sabéis tus registan türkmenistán y
tayikistán kirguistán kazajistán
pakistán y afganistán y es que veréis el
algodón tiene una propiedad muy curiosa
porque es una planta que no soporta
heladas así que necesita un clima cálido
pero sin llegar a los 35 grados además
lo ideal es que haya poca humedad
ambiental porque durante el proceso de
recogida el algodón tiene que estar seco
pero a la vez necesita muchísima agua
para cultivarse por ejemplo para plantar
200 gramos de algodón que es lo que
puede servir para hacer esta camiseta se
necesitan 2 mil litros de agua pues bien
de toda el agua que se usa en las
labores agrícolas el 35 por ciento va
exclusivamente para la producción del
algodón
[Música]
y ahora si te pones a buscar en el mapa
un lugar que sea cálido pero no
demasiado sin heladas pero con un clima
medianamente seco y que a la vez tenga
mucha agua pues lo cierto es que te vas
a encontrar con bastantes pocas zonas
con condiciones óptimas para el cultivo
de algodón y por eso que el 73% del
algodón mundial se produce gracias a
sistemas de irrigación y eso significa
que si se cultiva mucho algodón se gasta
mucha mucha agua tanta que hay regiones
enteras que están perdiendo sus ríos y
lagos debido a la producción masiva del
oro blanco y que dados con esto porque
en unos minutos os voy a hablar de la
mayor tragedia acuática jamás causada
por el autor
pero no sólo hablamos de catástrofes
ecológicas sino también humanitarias
porque hay países en los que el algodón
se recoge por mano de obra esclava o
incluso infantil
y lo que es peor es muy difícil saber si
la camiseta que llevas puesta ahora
mismo es una de esas prendas hechas por
trabajo forzoso porque la cadena de
producción del algodón es una de las más
complejas del mundo os voy a contar la
historia de una camiseta de algodón como
puede ser esta que llevo puesta
[Música]
primero se plante una semilla en un
campo de estos de los que os hemos
hablado cálido seco y con mucha agua
unos meses después alguien tiene que
recoger las típicas bolitas de algodón y
llevarlas a una fábrica de desmotado
donde la pelusa se separa de la semilla
y de cualquier tipo de impurezas la
pelusa de algodón que es lo que se
utiliza en la industria textil viaja a
otro lugar en el que se lava y se pasa
por una prensa para convertirse en un
bloque de algodón que también se llama
bala pues bien esta bala pasa a la
siguiente fase de producción en la que
se transforma en un hilo luego viene el
proceso de tejido en el que ese hilo se
convierte en una tela y finalmente
alguien confeccionará nuestra camiseta
que después puede pasar a los
escaparates de las principales marcas de
moda
ahora bien todo lo que se ha contado
podría ocurrir en un solo país pero la
verdad es que esto no es lo más
frecuente lo más habitual es que el
algodón se recoge en el país y se
transforma en tejido en el país se
confecciona en el país
y se venda finalmente en el país de
hablamos de un sector súper tradicional
con una cadena de producción larguísima
y un montón de manos por las que la bola
de algodón pasa antes de convertirse en
una camiseta o en un billete
por eso al final es muy difícil saber
quién produce el algodón crudo que se
acaba por utilizar para confeccionar las
camisetas de cualquier tienda y ya sé lo
que estaréis preguntando ahora mismo si
el algodón tiene tantísima demanda
porque no se recoge de forma
automatizada pues puede que os sorprenda
pero la agricultura es uno de los
sectores que más ha cambiado en el
último siglo es más a día de hoy casi
nadie recoge trigo a mano lo hacen
máquinas cosechadoras entonces en el
caso del algodón porque se siguen
utilizando a niños pequeños para
recogerlo pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
la trampa soviética normalmente cuando
se habla de los grandes imperios del
mundo todos pensamos en las colonias
británicas francesas y españolas pero
nadie piensa en el imperio ruso todos
damos por sentado que rusia es grande
pues pues porque rusia es grande sin más
yo que sé que cuando los primeros países
del mundo se repartieron toda la tierra
del planeta rusia dijo dame dos y le
tocó el comodín pues no obviamente no en
realidad el gran imperio ruso se fue
expandiendo muy poco a poco y solo se
hizo grande como tal en el siglo 18
cuando se quedó con toda siberia pero no
creáis que se quedaron ahí siguieron
expandiéndose por el sur hasta llegar a
asia central y ahí es donde encontrarán
el lugar perfecto para plantar
[Música]
cálido seco ya la vez con varios ríos el
problema el problema era que por alguna
razón no se fiaban de toda esa población
que acababan de anexionar por la fuerza
además como buenos colonizadores
pensaban que eran la raza superior y que
por tanto toda la producción tenía que
estar siempre en manos de empleadores y
empresarios rusos ahora avanzamos hasta
octubre del año 1917 que pasó en esa
fecha exacto
había un imperio ruso o la unión de
repúblicas socialistas soviéticas
así que el partido comunista dijo ahora
todos somos una hermandad no os
preocupéis camaradas hoy por ti mañana
por mí a ver asia central tú sigues ahí
produciendo algodón como si no existiera
mañana y a cambio nosotros el resto de
la unión soviética ya nos encargaremos
de que nos falte de nada y todo esto
explica que uzbekistán produjera dos
tercios de todo el algodón de la unión
soviética
y me diréis vale pues muy bien y qué
tiene de malo que uzbekistán produzca
mucho algodón pues creedme es un
problema recordáis que cultivar algodón
requiere de muchísima agua pero pero
muchísima agua pues bien
uzbekistán es un país prácticamente
desértico así que de dónde creéis que
sacaron el agua la respuesta está en el
mar de aral y si os pido que me señalase
en un mapa donde está el mar de aral más
os vale daros prisa porque está
prácticamente vacío tal cual como lo oís
el mar de aral es uno de los lagos de
agua salada más grandes del mundo más
bien deberíamos decir que era fijaos
y el mar de aral está más bien debería
decir estaba en la frontera entre
uzbekistán y kazajistán y a su vez
estaba nutrido por varios ríos pues bien
lo que hizo el partido comunista fue
decir a ver aquí tenemos el cuarto lago
más grande del mundo con un montón de
vida acuática y totalmente dependiente
de los ríos podemos desviar el agua de
estos ríos hacia las plantaciones del
algodón y a ver qué pasa como os podéis
imaginar cuando los ríos amu darya y
serdar ya dejaron de llenar el mar de
aral este fue desapareciendo poco a poco
a todo esto sumarle que como la unión
soviética era el país comunista por
excelencia toda la producción incluidas
las plantaciones de algodón estaba en
manos del estado y todo esto que
significa pues que los que trabajaban en
estos campos no eran los dueños de la
tierra es decir no se quedaban con el
algodón que recogían y tenían que
cumplir unas cuotas de entrega de
algodón altísimas pero por otra parte el
campo no era de su propiedad y podían
dejar de gestionarlo tan pronto como el
comité de turno se lo dijera conclusión
no tenían ningún incentivo para invertir
y maquinaria ella se lo que estaréis
pensando en los años 90 tanto uzbekistán
como tayikistán se independizaron y si
tenéis razón pero sus economías estaban
pensadas para exportar un único producto
algo
pensadlo bien si ya es un problema
depender del petróleo que tiene mucha
más demanda y menos productores
imaginando qué pasa si dependes del
algodón de un día para otro uzbekistán
competía en el mercado internacional
cara a cara con eeuu y con china no
tenían tecnología y tampoco tenían
empresas que produjeran otra cosa pero
aquí no termina la historia por mucho
que los países de asia central
los llamados instan se independizaran de
la unión soviética la propiedad de la
tierra seguía en manos del estar atentos
la tierra sus minerales aguas fauna y
flora y otros recursos naturales
constituirán la riqueza nacional y serán
racionalmente utilizados y protegidos
por el estado artículo 55 constitución
de uzbekistán
las tierras sus entrañas el agua el
espacio áereo la flora y la fauna y los
demás recursos naturales serán propiedad
del estado y el estado garantizará su
uso efectivo en interés del pueblo
artículo 13 constitución de tayikistán
habéis oído bien en estos países toda la
tierra le pertenece al estado y esto
significa que puedes tener la suerte de
que te ceda en una finca pero a cambio
tendrás que plantar lo que el estado te
diga que tienes que plantar así que una
vez más a los agricultores no les
compensa hacer grandes inversiones en
maquinaria pero no sólo eso aunque sea
menos eficiente el algodón recogido a
mano se paga mucho mejor porque tiene
supuestamente mejor calidad para que os
hagáis una idea un kilo de algodón
recogido a mano se paga atentos 16
céntimos más caro que el que se recoge a
máquina dicho de otra forma tanto eeuu
como europa recogen el algodón a máquina
y por eso pueden ofrecer precios mucho
más competitivos de uzbekistán y el
resto de países de asia central la única
forma en la que pueden competir estos
países es con
del algodón recogido a mano más que nada
porque hay muy pocos productores de este
tipo si a esto le sumamos que hablamos
de dictaduras salvajes nos encontramos
con barbaridades como esta
uzbekistán tiene la segunda prevalencia
más alta de esclavitud moderna en el
mundo cada año hasta 2 millones de
personas trabajaban en las plantaciones
sus becas de algodón en contra de su
voluntad y eso incluía a niños
básicamente llegaba el mes de septiembre
y en vez de comprarse una agenda nueva
los estudiantes y sus profesores cogían
un bus iban a una plantación de algodón
y se les ponía a trabajar
y que os parezca increíble pero esta ha
sido la realidad ibex tan hasta hace
sólo un par de años como os podéis
imaginar cuando esto salió a la luz en
los medios internacionales el gobierno
de cómo intentó maquillar un poco la
situación y prohibió el trabajo infantil
en los campos de algodón pero no lo
hicieron del todo bien aunque los niños
dejarán de trabajar en las plantaciones
sus profesores sí que seguían pasando
septiembre octubre y noviembre
recogiendo algodón conclusión los niños
uzbekos no podían ir al colegio pero
ahora la pregunta es y qué ha ocurrido
para cambiar esta situación porque de la
noche a la mañana
uzbekistán ha prohibido la esclavitud
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
es el mercado amigo mira la etiqueta de
tu camiseta estoy seguro de que no pone
made in el petista seguramente ponga
algo estilo made in turquía un mailing
bangladesh y diréis porque se están
mintiendo como suele ocurrir siempre la
respuesta es compleja os acordáis de la
cadena de producción del algodón que
decíamos que es una de las más largas y
complejas del mundo y que me decís si os
cuento que el país que más algodón
importa de países como türkmenistán y
tayikistán uzbekistán es turquía
y que a su vez turquía es uno de esos
países donde tienen sus fábricas
textiles empresas como inditex night o
h&m ahora empieza a tener todo sentido
verdad efectivamente turquía es donde
los mayores apps de algodón de europa
recibe la materia cruda de asia central
y la convierte en ropa o la envía a
grandes fábricas textiles de otros
países
es casi imposible trazar de dónde viene
el algodón de tu camiseta sin embargo
estoy seguro de que ninguno de vosotros
compraría una camiseta donde ha
intervenido mano de obra esclava por
supuesto existe un enorme debate en
torno a los países de mano de obra
barata pero en nadie absolutamente nadie
defiende la esclavitud y alguno pensará
a esas multinacionales les da igual
esclavizar a quien sea con tal de ganar
dinero pues bien aunque eso fuera cierto
a los consumidores no y tampoco a las
ongs ni a los tribunales internacionales
y diréis y cuál es la solución entonces
pues por una parte los sellos de calidad
ahora mismo hay un montón de organismos
que se encargan de supervisar la
producción del algodón y sólo ponen el
sello si saben que no hay niños ni
esclavos involucrados y esto explica
noticias como esto
[Música]
uzbekistán más de 100 empresas evitan el
algodón uzbeko efectivamente esto es lo
que pasó en el año 2012
de repente uzbekistán perdió a casi
todos sus compradores y no solamente
hablamos de empresas también hablamos de
gobiernos
los legisladores de la unión europea
bloquean el acuerdo textil con
uzbekistán por preocupaciones sobre el
trabajo infantil vamos yo sé que están
se convirtió en algo así como el gollum
de los países pequeño despreciado y
obsesionado con su tesoro el algodón
pero no sólo eso
uzbekistán necesitaba reducir su
dependencia del algodón
por ejemplo necesitaban empezar a
cultivar trigo para no tener que
importarlo por otra parte si querían
seguir vendiendo algodón no les quedaba
otro remedio que dejar la esclavitud y
todo esto explica que desde el año 2012
este país ha ido reformando sus
políticas primero dejaron de obligar a
los niños a cultivar algodón después
dejaron de esclavizar a los funcionarios
y no sólo hablamos de un cambio
cosmético según la organización
internacional del trabajo que no es que
sean precisamente amigos del gobierno de
uzbekistán el 94% de las personas que
recogían el algodón en el año 2019 lo
hacían voluntariamente por supuesto aún
sigue existiendo un 6 por ciento de mano
de obra esclava pero pensad que hablamos
de cambiar el sistema sobre el que se ha
sustentado toda la economía nacional
becado durante décadas
lo que estaréis pensando pero si os x
tan no tiene tecnología y ahora no
tienen esclavos como pueden ser
competitivos en el mercado internacional
la respuesta está en la raíz del
problema porque no hay tractores en
uzbekistán exacto porque no existe
iniciativa privada solución cambiar las
reglas del juego
pakistán empezará a privatizar la tierra
a partir del año que viene
mientras que china se enfrenta a las
sanciones estadounidenses por el trabajo
forzoso pakistán se convierte en un
modelo
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando venga a
fonseca de verdad una dictadura tan
corrupta como los beckham va a vender oa
privatizar los campos de cultivo de
forma transparente pues tenéis toda la
razón la privatización del algodón
uzbeko es de todo menos limpia y las
leyes son bastante confusas en realidad
lo que han hecho ha sido ceder el
cultivo de los campos de algodón y el
procesamiento del mismo a empresarios
privados uno por cada región es decir
que cada uno de estos empresarios tiene
el monopolio del algodón en su región y
sin duda alguna el gran beneficiado de
toda esta privatización es una empresa
local que se llama uf text hablamos del
mayor conglomerado de uzbekistán y que
tiene conexiones muy claras con el
gobierno esta empresa se ha hecho con
los cultivos de la mayor parte de las
regiones pero seamos honestos la
corrupción no es nada que no conocieran
ya a los pobres uzbekos ahora al menos
están empezando a ver maquinaria
agrícola
campos
[Música]
uzbekistán acelera la mecanización de la
recogida del algodón pero esperado
momento si pensabas que ha bastado con
privatizar el campo para acabar con la
esclavitud de una vez por todas estáis
muy equivocados muchas de estas fábricas
tienen problemas para encontrar mano de
obra pensando bien antes era tan
sencillo como obligar a todo el mundo a
recoger algodón ahora tienen que
acostumbrarse a hacer contratos de
trabajo y en muchos casos algunas de
estas granjas privadas están recurriendo
a las autoridades locales para que
vuelvan a obligar a la gente a trabajar
recordad que seguimos hablando de una
dictadura donde no existe estado de
derecho todavía hoy muchos políticos
locales pueden usar a la policía para
esclavizar a la función
por otra parte los trabajadores libres
tampoco tienen unas condiciones
envidiables en estos momentos un
recolector de algodón cobra alrededor de
dos euros y medio al día esto es un
sueldo bajo incluso para los estándares
uzbekos sin embargo tenemos que
reconocerlo el uzbekistán del año 2020
es mucho más justo que el del año 2012 y
lo que es más importante todos estos
nuevos terratenientes están empezando a
invertir en fábricas de procesado de
algodón es decir que en unos años
uzbekistán podría dejar de exportar
algodón crudo y empezar a vender
productos de mayor valor añadido como
hilo de algodón o incluso ropa pero
ahora turno para ti crees que las
reformas sus becas son un buen ejemplo
para otros países productores de algodón
te parece que las sanciones
internacionales podrían ser útiles
contra el trabajo esclavo en xinjiang
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribió ssa visual
político y darle a la campanita para que
llegue una notificación cada vez que
sacamos un vídeo nuevo recordad también
que tenemos un nuevo canal mega projects
con cada de visual político donde
hablamos de grandes proyectos de
ingeniero
y si os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a
like y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo
y hasta pronto
[Música]